hey guys and welcome back to the channel
today we will be doing yet another video
about cashing I'm thinking for the next
few weekends I'm probably going to be
doing some nons systems design related
content uh got a little collaboration
coming up this weekend but of course for
the weekdays we're on our grind so sit
back crack open a Red Bull and let's get
into this thing all right so let's go
ahead and get into it so to get started
since it's been a week since our last
video let's go ahead and do a very quick
distributed caching recap basically
there are a couple of big Pros here uh
the main one being reading of course our
cach might be physically closer to us it
might be using faster storage and
potentially we might even get big
benefits on rights though to that point
that's still a little bit unclear and
we'll discuss that mainly during this
video another thing is that effectively
if we have a nice caching layer it can
act as a little bit of a wall between
our actual database and our users and
thus reduce some of the load another uh
kind of less ideal thing about caching
but still nonetheless there is that cash
misses are expensive and we always want
to be considering this whenever we have
to reach out to the cash that's going to
take an extra Network call and in
addition to that we actually have to go
ahead and search the cache now if this
is a hashmap based cach then that's
really good for us because you know o of
one time complexity is relatively fast
but sometimes caches can be implemented
with something like a tree map that
isn't necessarily constant time
complexity and it could add some extra
time to your data accesses
so again there's extra disk and network
iio there or instead of dis sometimes
maybe memory if that's how we're
choosing to implement our cache then the
last thing is going to be that data
consistency and correctness can be tough
because we have more places to
potentially read and write our data from
and two that is going to complicate
things and that's what we'll mainly be
talking about today so we're going to be
talking about three different ways of
actually going ahead and writing to our
databases and getting that correct data
in our cach so let's start with the
first one which is going to be the most
simple and most similar to what you
would do if you didn't have a cache
which is you would just go ahead and
write to the database like normal so the
reason this is called a write around
cach is because we're literally writing
around it as you can see right here
let's imagine that we've got Kate Upton
lovely lady and she thinks that I'm a 10
out of 10 but previously it was agreed
upon that I'm a nine the first thing
that she would do is write to the
database and that's very typical we've
seen that pretty much all throughout
anything in systems so far however now
we're going to do a couple of extra
things and actually effectively we've
got two options here so one I'm going to
be calling invalidation the other I'll
call a stale read so the stale read
would be Kate Upton has written to the
database but then you know we don't
really do anything and you know when she
next reads from the cache so see that uh
Jordan is nine which is obviously not
going to be the case because she just
wrote 10 so notice that we have this guy
right here a TTL and effectively the TTL
in a cache says like Beyond a point
we're going to EXP fire this data so as
you can see it's Tuesday here so when
Wednesday comes
around what would happen is this whole
thing gets removed kupton is going to
make another read request from the cach
the cach is going to say I don't have it
and then it's going to ask the database
which is going to say Jordan is a 10 so
that's one option and it's pretty simple
it's just you know we get a stale read
until our data expires another option is
we can take a more active approach to
this so let's go ahead and get rid of
this stuff blah blah blah BL blah oh no
I have to to draw another box and
effectively now what Kate Upton would do
is the second that she performs this
right over here she's also going to
invalidate the Jordan
key and what this does is now the cash
is going to either say okay well uh it's
empty now so the next time she
reads the cash is going to say I don't
have Jordan ask the database for it the
database comes back with the value the
cash populates itself with the new value
for Jordan and then then returns it to
Kate Upton with Jordan is 10 so you can
see that in the case of the stale read
it's a matter of incorrect
data in the case of
invalidation we'll get the updated
right and so of course you have to make
the tradeoff of when do you actually
need correct data is it okay to make a
right and then not instantly see it that
of course is use case dependent but the
thing to note here is that in both of
these implementations we have an
expensive cash Miss we now have to
basically route our networking call
through our cash as a result of the fact
that we made a new right and now the
cach doesn't have the data at the same
time wrs are very simple we would do a
write just like normal write to the
database and the database remains our
source of Truth which is good because it
means that adding a bunch of readon
caches doesn't affect the way that we're
already doing our existing rights which
technically makes them a little bit
easier in theory okay now let's talk
about the right through cache this is
when we really start getting cheeky so
again there are a couple of approaches
that we can take here to do this why is
it called a write through cach well of
course when Karina COV here decides that
I am yet again a 10 out of 10 and
updates the cach which previously had me
as a nine this value gets updated to a
10 and then at the same exact time the
cash is also going to write to the
database it's going to proxy that
request say that I'm a 10 out of 10 and
the database is going to update its
value now obviously something should be
standing out to you here which is that
it is always possible that either this
right gets made and then this network
request doesn't go through or you know
just any other thing could happen this
right gets made and this cash like goes
down or something and then you know it
gets loaded back up on a stale replica
but the point is that unless you have
two-phase Commit it is possible here to
have data inconsistencies because at the
end of the day it's possible for your
cash and your database to get out of
sync now if you do use two-phase commit
then that is slow because that's just
how two-phase commit is it would take
quite a few more Network calls I'd first
have to make a network call here I'd
have to make one here they' both have to
respond okay to say they're ready to
commit and then now I'd have to make
even more Network calls back to them to
say commit and that's expensive right
now that being said with the right
through cash you of course can always
take the YOLO approach because sometimes
you just don't need to have super
consistent data it's nice when you do
mostly have that because most of the
time time will be fine but you do open
yourself up to the occasional fault
where you would be in trouble so what
are the overall pros and cons of these
approaches well basically of course we
do have nice data consistency simply
because of the fact that whenever you
write to the cache that write is also
going to the database and vice versa but
at the same time a it's relatively slow
because you have to write data to a
couple of places and B especially in the
two-phase commit case it's super slow so
again kind of use case dependent when
you want to be using this there's
definitely no objective solution here so
the last approach that we're going to be
talking about is the right back cache
why is it called right back because
first when Megan Fox over here yet
another baddy decides that I'm a 10 out
of 10 the first thing that's going to
happen is we write to the cache and then
at some point down the
line or better yet let's say
asynchronously will eventually write
that back to the database and then the
database can go ahead and update that
value but there's no guarantees when
that gets written one thing that a
certain lot of write back cash setups
like to do is lower the amount of load
on the database by many batching the
rights that they've taken on that
haven't yet gone to the database so for
example let's say Megan also decided
that besides me being a 10 Machine Gun
Kelly her current boyfriend is a two
because I'm more attractive and Donald
Trump is a one that's obvious so it's
possible that we would effectively mini
batch these
rights and send them all to the database
at once it's a lot more efficient than
having to send many different things
over the network just makes life easy
now of course this comes with a couple
of issues if this cash has a certain
value for a certain amount of time and
this guy tries to read from the database
it's very possible that they won't see
the up-to-date result because the right
back cash hasn't written it back yet so
what could we do if we really needed to
have consistent data here well we could
have something like a distributed
locking service so whenever we wrote to
the cach you know what we would also
have to do is grab the distributed lock
and say Jordan is
grabbed and effectively as long as the
right back cache has the value Jordan
and hasn't yet written it back to the
database it's going to stay this way of
course that being said if this guy wants
to go ahead and read from Jordan he
would have to try and grab the
distributed lock the distributed lock
would then notify the right back cache
that someone is trying to read the value
Jordan can or rather the right back
cache could then write the value to the
database and say Jordan is 10 this is
all because we tried to grab that
distributed lock and then finally we
would get the up-to-date read value now
of course that does Ure that this guy is
going to see an upto-date value but it's
possible that Megan Fox could write the
value and no one else would ever see it
how well if the cache just fails before
it manages to write back to the database
of course in combination using something
like distributed locking and cash replic
a does solve our problem here but not
only does it add a ton of complexity to
our system it also adds a ton of latency
and in many ways kind of just defeats
the point of using a right back cache
the whole reason we want a right back
cache is so that our rights are super
fast we're writing to a low latency
place and so as a result of that I don't
know personally even though technically
you could make the case that I don't
know something like GitHub is
technically right back caching with a
distributed lock because effectively
there's one centralized server you know
to make a commit you have to to
effectively grab the lock and by writing
files locally you're effectively caching
them you know generally speaking when I
think of write back caching I just think
of writing to the cach and hopefully
things work out okay so generally
speaking I'm going to be talking about
the YOLO approach when I use this method
which is effectively just right to the
right back cach and hope things go all
right so the pros like I mentioned quick
wrs the cons well if that cash goes down
you're in trouble and uh if this guy
over here decides to read the value
before the cash is written back you're
also in trouble of course if your
application doesn't care about data
staleness issues then that's great that
would be a good example of a time that
you would want to use a writeback cache
so what are our conclusions well like I
mentioned earlier all of these types of
writing have very different use cases
and you're basically going to optimize
different things by choosing one
approach or another so there really is
no clear winner here each of them have
very distinctive pros and cons but by
knowing the pros and cons you can make
the right decision for your application
so like I mentioned for write around
you're effectively just writing to the
database like you normally would and as
a result of that probably a little bit
less complex but at the same time you're
getting less benefit on reads due to
having to get an initial cash Miss at
the same time you've got right through
cash which is effectively where you're
just either using a two-phase commit to
make sure that everything is super
consistent or you're not and hoping
things go okay in theory this is a
little bit better because your cash and
your database are nice and synced up and
the data is already in your cach and
then finally we've got the right back
cach which is the real YOLO thing here
write as quickly as possible and then
eventually go ahead and put that data in
the database but if things go down in
the meantime you're probably in trouble
again if your application can tolerate
that and you just care about giving
users quick rights then that's a really
useful thing anyways guys I hope these
tradeoffs make sense uh hopefully
decently sensible video and I hope that
you can take this knowledge with you
into your systems design interview have
a great day and I will see you in the
next one